[Musique]
capucine la boîte numéros unes c'est la
dernière fois que je vous le demande
est-ce que vous gardez la boîte numéro
une est ce que vous voulez changer avec
celle de mathieu vidard d'aïn regarder
la lune des questions non non non on est
à préciser les règles fini c'est fini
ces questions oui si la personne call
prime ne se sent pas deux par deux
verges de l'animé est ce qu'elle peut
choisir s'il ya une personne si la
question nous mathieu c'est votre boîte
mathieu j'ai une question à vous poser
est ce que vous décidez de changer de
prendre la boîte de capucine wii prend
là mais non non ils ne le prennent à
tampa ne sera baptisé de façon
[Applaudissements]
mathieu c'est horrible dix mois mathieu
oui est-ce qu'on prenait la boîte de
capucine lorsqu'on regarde et l'adaf et
pourquoi on appellerait l'ocl été
attribués sert il regarda peut-être
kaffer mais j'ai changé de boîte
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les espèces changé je vais changer mais
c'est pas honnête et pourquoi il m'a
pris mon état pas déranger mais bon
merci d'être avec nous aujourd'hui c'est
la police des nations unies
attention ce call on lit dans ce cas
dans ce film fort à son cyril s'il est
un peu élégant même s'ils gagnent ils
avaient le personnel se passera devant
commenté à merci oui ils ont pas un
cadeau pour tout le monde
moi je sais ce qu'il a dans la voiture
mais je ne sais pas ce qu'il ya dans la
boîte les chéris je vous le dis je vous
le répète sommes en face d'un problème
épineux
allawi mathieu mathieu est ce que vous
changé de boîte
est-ce que vous changé de boîte mais
comprenez a brillé dans l'échangé de
boîte et prenez votre numéro une
écoutez les conseils de personnes non
j'ai écouté mon coeur mais s'il avait
ouvert tout à l'heure s'il vous plaît ce
sujet mais la wii hu est énorme et à la
peau et les riches is est ce que vous
voulez la boîte une ou la boîte nommée
ans je vais les chiffres ce n'est pas
ton truc cool et la une oui là pardon je
ne changeais donc rejoindre s est moqué
insurgés je vais vous dire il reste tout
le prime
non la photo sexy et qui vais le dire à
la fin du printemps
sur les 2 15 ans drame
[Applaudissements]
je vais faire un tour de table et je
vais demander à mes créateurs de se
décider est ce que vous préférez voir en
prime capucine avoue matthieu delormeau
la boîte de capucine c'est la une la
boîte de match et c'est la 9 e sur
twitter type nouveau gillot préféré que
quatre fusils ils bien entendu thierry
capucine jean michel mathieu
géraldine matthieu valéry capucine c'est
pas ça m'embête de le dire mais pour son
professionnalisme
capucine
[Applaudissements]
alors pour que le suspense reste entier
je vais donc dire mathieu mathieu oui
benjamins n'ont pas je voudrais pas mal
à son sens de l'antenne de la répartie
bien sûr que possible la piscine est ce
que vous sentez les porter à price à son
agenda en tout cas sa main sur mon lev
mignonet elle ne marcherait pas cramé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sur ces huit matches bah oui baoulé maga
je vous pose la question
avec ses 8 c'est pas nrj 12 à ces
niveaux dessus il a quand même fait ou
la cour des grands vous êtes dans la
congrégation de qualité c'est que ça
fait deux ans deux ans que je me prépare
la petite a comme ses pairs frais et ben
deux ans quand même j'attends mano par
isabelle capi est très clair je voudrais
vérifier ce que vient de dire mathieu tu
as dit il n'était pas prêt pour un
prince sont vérifiées donc je des
capucines abattant le maire mais parce
que genre c'est la vie de maman qui va
tout faire basculer
bah non la vie de maman didon quoi les
fans vont voter gervais des capucines
bien entendu on va voir la vie des
tweetos sachez vous allez avoir des
surprises
les deux mairies de la voir des
surprises regardez l écriture âpre et
surprise
[Applaudissements]
il avait choisi capucine pour présenter
un prime time chaussée si vous nous
rejoignez les familles sont lucides
joignez sur la dernière journée dans un
instant doha les animateurs ne rien dire
il en a plein de choses on aura
également tous les sauvegardes des
chroniqueurs je vous dis ça va être une
soirée exceptionnelle et après on aura
très très gros prime pour le moment les
chéris il ya la boîte 9
on va refaire savoir-faire tout le truc
au départ en voiture devant moi vais la
voir alors boistron c'était une baba by
night c'est à dire une soir adéquat dans
un hôtel + nuits d'hôtel etc
ensuite vous avez eu la boîte numéro 8 8
vous avez changé clavier ensuite vous
avez pris la rfid avec la boîte 9
matthieu delormeau votre rêve c'est de
présenter un prime sur ces huit
capucines à la votre rêve bas à la base
c'était pas ça parce que je me sens un
peu trop scène mais maintenant qu'il est
adéquat votre cadeau rêvé à la bonne
sortie n ont pas été conçu et imprimé et
end au ski à andorre s'il n'avait volé
quoi tu voulais kouassi non pas dans
tout imprègne voilà les chéris petit
d'offrir 10 sinon il ya une photo et
friend is a lie ya une photo sexy de
mokhtar
je vous le dis il y aura vraiment un
prime pour l'un ou pour l'autre
sur ces huit rien pas de nuit à la
rentrée 2010 sec
mathieu j'ouvre votre boîte
[Musique]
c'est fini
quel cadeau de matthieu delormeau qu'il
ya là dedans matthieu delormeau en
touche mokhtar vous allez mais c'est sur
ces mots que tard dans un instant on va
se retrouver pour le moment la tension
est à son comble puisque matthieu
delormeau et capucine à naves sont les 2
restants matthieu delormeau et capucine
halal c'est une histoire
dans cette émission matthieu delormeau
est arrivé il ya deux ans et venait
d'nrj 12 mois je les mets sur nrj j'aime
également sur ses 8 c'est quelqu'un qui
a beaucoup apporté à cette émission et
qui en 2010 est un portrait encore plus
son rêve à matthieu rosset tous ces de
gravir les échelons du paf
j'ai un peu il est déjà très haut il est
déjà très haut mais voudrait aller
encore plus haut et pour aller plus haut
comme disait tina arena rien sur faut
des prime time dès 20h50 opaque yeux de
leur mort on n'avait jamais présenté de
20h50 sur ces vitesses que c'est votre
raid
oui oui c'est votre raid m'a tuer en
face de vous qu'il n'ya plus que deux
cadeaux il ya capucines à naves
capucines à naves
elle vient également d nrj 12 elle est
arrivé l'année dernière
au départ on était mi figue mi raisin
sur son arrivée et puis petit à petit
s'est intégré dans l'équipe
mais aujourd'hui même est une des pièces
maîtresses de touche pas à mon poste
également du gouvernement français
capucine à naves ce que vous avez déjà
présenté une émission tout seul capucine
avec benoît sur nrj12 n'ont pas quitté
seulement avec benoît c'est comme si on
était tous je rigole j'adore benoît en
plus ça va alors si on peut plus vannes
et vous n'est jamais une émission toute
seule empreinte taille g8 une grande
chaîne
c'est ce que c'est votre raid ça fait
partie de mes rêves
oui je ne les ai pas le dire parce que
sinon on a laissé deux mois les raisons
qui allait voir
[Applaudissements]
avant de voir ce qu'il y a comme cadeau
j'aimerais tous les deux vous appeliez
la personne la plus proche de vous et
vous lui disiez je vais peut-être
présenter un prime sur ses mythes appel
oui j'ai appelé mon père de l'appeler
votre père way alésia p2 on va là mais
on va le mettre au fait on va le mettre
votre père on va le placer en haut par
le gym nous battre à l'appliquer sur
coach mon meilleur pote emmanuel
emmanuel qui macron
alors allez-y capucine appelez votre
papa dit du blizzard peut-être et encore
lui dire non tu donnes tu vas te calme
et tu vas pas dire grand chose pour nous
et après après mathieu vous avez appelé
on découvrira les boîtes juste après une
émission folle aujourd'hui c'est bon
votre père il habite dans la région
alliant millions à lyon traverse une
telle région à huy papous oui chérie tu
es un direct sur sur ces 8
évidemment oui je voulais est annoncé
que je vais peut-être une chance sur
deux présente et en chantant
j'en conviens mais mon nom ne parlera ne
marche pas je crois pas c'est le mois
oui monsieur
c'est cyril hanouna oui je suis
surveillant de votre fille aujourd hui
nous sommes en plein d'émissions en
direct
alors ouais qui ne passent que est-ce
que vous m'entendez très mal c'est
normal monsieur monsieur c'est quoi
votre prénom
alain didier didier didier capucine va
peut-être présenter un prime sur s'est
vite ça va jouer entre elles et matthieu
delormeau
est ce que ça vous fait quelque chose
mathieu et des bons merci
[Applaudissements]
là alors vous préférez que ce soit
mathieu n'ont pas et préféré que ce soit
sa fille oui vous êtes content on vous
rappelle tendent à me faire chier son
père merci on leur bras se dit attention
lin zhang appel mais vous êtes en ligne
avec j'appelais emmanuel ouais c'est mon
meilleur ami emmanuel aux manuels reyel
au soleil et emmanuel mathieu va
peut-être présenté à prime sur ces 8
vous est son meilleur ami
pour vous c'est une bonne ou une
mauvaise nouvelle a toujours au départ
tullow par non et bien emmanuel vous le
saurez comme les téléspectateurs dans un
instant parce que j'ouvrais les boîtes
ramos j'en ai rien à [ __ ] et c'est que
j'ai le niveau où il a suivi toute ma
carrière quoi eh bien il faut mettre ces
mythes je peux pas vous garder au
téléphone ça coûte cher
dix mille personnes cap lc 10 me les
cherry et les torts de voix il ya une
photo de mokhtar ou après une table sur
6,8
capucine adam dernière chance vous
gardez votre boîte du merlu nous voulait
changer que mathieu et ce sera la
dernière je la garde ou la garde et j'ai
terminé
capucine adam qui est derrière cette
boîte
il y à une photo de mokhtar vous
repartir avec une photo de l'otage de
mokhtar vous amènera d'ailleurs ce n'est
pas la peine de dire à la déprime et
tout ceci il n'y a pas si les écrits
photos de mokhtar ici c'est que c'est
matthieu delormeau présentera le prime
time sur ces huit en 2017
il faisait de la boîte de capucine je le
rappelle c'est pas bon capucine votre
cadeau de noël
votre cadeau de noël qui a pu s'y colla
trois cadeaux de noël
monsieur nouvelle star
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en fait jean ferrat
je verrai si comme m et derrière il y
avait bien une photo sexy dollars
[Applaudissements]
mais je veux bien quoi animer avec lui
six ans dans la vallée
merci la double peine mathieu les olé y
aura d'autres occasions
je vous le dis on fera la même chose il
y aura des cadeaux pour la saint
valentin un génial d'accord vers le 14
février
mathieu je sais que vous êtes déçu mon
chéri mais vous avez le talent c'est
essentiel maintenant faut le montrer
sera pas pour cette fois
bah oui mais malheureusement vous
n'aurez pas l'occasion de mon prénom
c'est une bonne nouvelle on va passer